the planet we live on is is way more
Dynamic than anybody was even imagining
a generation ago global warming
scenarios they basically are coming out
of the 1980s before we had like
satellite surveys of Shifting sea levels
there were no solar satellites looking
at the sun in 1988 when global warming
was first proposed so it became very
easy to dismiss the role of the sun into
computer models well we know a whole lot
more about the sun now than we did back
then every single front of scientific
research into Earth history confirms
that that history of this planet is
extraordinarily Dynamic and is subject
to all kinds of changes we know now with
the younger driest for example at 1300
years the melting process was not only
stopped it was probably reversed and so
you had this period of Rapid melting
followed by this rapid shift back into
major glacial cold and then you had this
regrowth of the ice sheets